اسطوانه يبلغ طولها 30 سم بوزن 25 كلغ
لكنها خطيره حد تسببها باعراض مميته
لاحتوائها على ماده السيزيوم 137 عاليه
النشاط الاشعاعي فقدت في تايلاند الدوله
المكتظه بسته 66 مليون شخص تشكو ليبيا هي
الاخرى فقدان مواد نوويه في فترات متقاربه
حيث اكتشفت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
التابعه للامم المتحده اختفاء عشره براميل
تحتوي على ما يقرب من طنين ونصف من
اليورانيوم الطبيعي مكتفيه بالقول ان
الوصول الى الموقع الذي لا يخضع لسيطره
الحكومه يطلب لوجستيات معقده ووفق مصادر
محليه في العاصمه التايلانديه فان الانبوب
الفولاذيه مفقود في محافظه برتشمبوري ومن
اسيا الى افريقيا فان احد المواقع المعلنه
ل اليورانيوم في ليبيا هو سبها على بعد
نحو 660 كيلو مترا جنوب شرق العاصمه
طرابلس وفي الناحيه الاخرى مفاعل نووي
تجريبي بمدينه تاجوراء القريبه من الساحل
اعلان الوكاله الدوليه اعاد تسليط الضوء
على تركه المشروع النووي لنظام العقيد
الراحل معمر القذافي الذي قيل انه خزن
هناك في سبها الاف البراميل المكدسه اطلق
عليها اسم الكعكه الصفراء لم يكتب للمخطط
ان يبنى ضمن برنامج للاسلحه السريه دمى
عقدين من الزمن الا ان تلاشي اليورانيوم
المخزن في صحراء متراميه الاطراف اثار
مخاوف بيئيه وامنيه
خبراء حظر الانتشار النووي اوضحوا ان
استخدام اليورانيوم ليس سهلا بما فيه
الكفايه لكنهم حذروا من ان تلك المواد
الفتاكه اذا وقعت بايد غير امنه فستشكل
تهديدا كبيرا خاصه اذا ما كانت تمتلك
العصابه وسائل وموارد تكنولوجيه هنا تتمكن
من تحويل كل طن من اليورانيوم الى خمسه
كيلو جرامات و600 جرام من الماده
المستخدمه في صنع الاسلحه